grégory au départ toute cette affaire
vous aviez mis votre appartement en
location pour un temps limité ça parce
que vous êtes propriétaire d'un
appartement fait quoi dans la dgre y
êtes intermittents du spectacle c'est ça
monsieur artistes chanteurs et comédiens
dont vous avez pu mettre un peu d'argent
de côté vous êtes dit je vais essayer
d'acheter un appartement et des
militaires cc ou votre appartement à
rosny sous bois
d'accord pour les très bien 93 way a
très bien et donc vous acheter cet
appartement et pourquoi vous voulez le
mettre en location parce que vous
habitez ailleurs parce que je partais
pour un contrat d' accord pour une
allocation pour prendre un petit peu de
sous quand même pendant que pas là et je
me suis dit je vais surtout le mettre en
location pour des intermittents du
spectacle comme moi avons donc je me
suis dis parce que c'est très compliqué
pour des intermittents locataires de
trouver des
des propriétaires qui nous font
confiance donc je me suis dit je vais
tendre la main à des gens qui font le
même métier que moi et voilà donc
voulait le louis anglade cauchemar va
commencer puisque vous prenez des
locataires c'est ça ou way aller dès le
premier mois ils ont décidé de ne pas
payer les loyers et ça a été un petit
peu compliqué c'était toujours des
excuses en excuse pour wii on payera la
semaine prochaine promis etc etc puis en
fait ils paient jamais et quand vous
avez voulu récupérer l'appartement sait
comment vous êtes dit je vais récupérer
l'appartement que j'habitais donc c'est
normal ne plus louer ils ont décidé de
rester au sein du rectorat ils ont
décidé de ne pas me rendre le logement
en appartement donc du coup je suis
rentré en procès contre eux j'ai fait
appel à la justice pour régler cette
histoire j'ai trouvé une avocate
évidemment je j'ai payé des huissiers
etc et
et j'ai gagné le procès en eau
mi-novembre 2020 là et non malgré sa non
ça ne bouge pas et pourquoi ça bouge pas
et la traditionnelle trêve hivernale
trêve hivernale parce que alors il
faudrait que vous le retrouviez un autre
logement
incroyable alors moi j'ai essayé de j'ai
essayé de trouver des accords à
l'amiable avec eux j'ai c'est pour aider
des solutions pour qu'ils partent
d'eux-mêmes pour pour essayer d'éviter
tous à éviter de perdre trop d'argent
etc et il me devait à ce moment-là 4000
euros de loyers déjà et en fait ils
m'ont caché l'existence d'un bébé dans
ce logement ce qui complique absolument
tout paris est normal il me devait 4000
euros de loyer je leur ai dit écoutez je
veux bien m'asseoir sur cette somme
d'argent voulu garder pour l'enfant
garder ses 4000 euros occupez-vous de
l'enfant avec mais partez s'il vous
plaît partez
et ils n'ont rien voulu entendre j'ai
essayé de leur trouver des logements
alternatifs fin de de chercher des
annonces sur leboncoin sur ceux ci sur
ce même canton
ils n'ont rien voulu nantes en justement